welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Molly Brunson an associate professor
of Slavic languages and literatures her
research interests include 19th and 20th
century Russian prose the history of
Russian art from 18th century to the
present theories of realism and the
avant-garde and representations of the
city country and space today we'll talk
with professor Brunson about her book
Russian realisms literature and painting
1842 1890 welcome professor bunsen thank
you for having me it's great to talk
about this thank you
let's start with an overview of your
book tell sure about it
my book is about artistic realism in the
second half of the 19th century in
Russia this is the moment where Russian
literature's greatest masterpieces are
being written which is what most
famously the novels of Tolstoy and
Dostoevsky which almost everybody knows
are frequently taught all over the world
and - they're very well known the other
part of my book however is on the
painting of this period which is in fact
very little known outside of Russia even
though it still has an enormous impact
on the Russian cultural mentality okay
so the book as a whole then really is
thinking about the relationship between
the literary and painterly traditions in
the second half of the 19th century in a
certain sense you could say that this is
a case study of realism as it occurs in
Russia as part of an artistic movement
that is in fact pan-european in scope
this is a moment when artists and
writers all over Western Europe also in
America are thinking not about
Romanticism
not about romantic representations of
the world but about how they can
represent everyday people everyday
events everyday reality and often with a
kind of democratic or liberal point of
view
and so in this sense Russia very much as
part of this bigger picture
and so the book functions it in this way
is a kind of national case study okay
but on the other hand Russia is also
deviant within this tradition and this
is part of what makes Russia's realist
tradition so interesting is that there
are many ways in which it in fact
violates the realist project of Western
Europe the best example is probably
Dostoyevsky
who is writing novels that yes are about
the everyday or about the contemporary
but are also aiming to break through the
real break through the material and
reach some kind of transcendent vision
of spirituality and of human nature he
in fact calls this realism in a higher
sense okay and so this is the way that
Russian realism realism is in some sense
very different than its Western European
counterparts okay and what led you to
write the book what was the inspiration
well I was trained initially both in our
history and in literary studies so all
of my work aims to bring these two art
forms together in some capacity the
topic of realism itself actually emerged
in in a rather surprising way which is I
began a project thinking about the
realism of the 20th century and in
particular thinking about why the Soviet
Union turns to realism in the 1930s as a
state sanctioned official artistic
ideology across all of the art forms and
as I continue to work on that project it
struck me that I really had to figure
out what the 19th century realist
tradition meant for the Soviets in order
to properly understand this and so I
went to the 19th century initially just
to get a little bit of background and I
ended up never leaving and so what ended
up striking me first of all and the
reason why I never left was that the art
historian in me looked at this material
and said why has nobody talked about
these paintings we know so much about
Tolstoy Turgenev Dostoevsky but most
scholars most students in the West know
nothing about the painters that are
working at the same time
what who are some of the painters for
example ilya repin would probably be one
of the more famous ones that if you
happen to know anybody he would likely
be the one but the other is Ivanka Scoy
luckily petals popular doses likely none
of these names are familiar and that is
very common can you find some of those
paintings in the United States at this
point no and that is part of the reason
why they're so little known is that
because the Soviets actually looked at
this 19th century tradition as their
precursor to what they were doing these
works became really celebrated important
parts of a Soviet cultural heritage and
so they were never sold out of the
museum so they are all still there for
the most part there are some examples
here and there mostly they are in Moscow
and st. Petersburg so I looked at these
works and I said I have to do something
with him and I also then started to read
the literature through this lens and
thinking about how in fact the writers
themselves were also very interested in
what was going on in the visual arts
turgenyev at one point says that he
wishes he had been a landscape painter
the stay of he will write in his Diaries
again and again about the paintings he
sees on his trips to museums and so the
idea for the book then was really to
write a history of Russian realism that
was not over determined by the novel
okay and that would bring the literature
and the painting into productive
dialogue with one another and really
make their histories commensurate okay
and how did you do the research what was
your methodology I imagine you'd like to
see some of the paintings and yeah I you
know this was a huge part of the project
was the importance of not only just
going to see the paintings walking
through a museum but spending a lot of
time with them one of the very few
references to the 19th century Russian
realist tradition and painting in the
West happens in a very curious place
there's an article written in 1939 by a
modernist art critic named Clement
Greenberg who's very well known to our
historians he's part of the sort of
introductory 20th century survey and he
writes this article he publishes it in
the United States and in it he
as he sort of posits this hypothetical
comparison between two painters one of
them is Pablo Picasso and the other is
as it turns out ilya repin this is maybe
the only reference to ilya repin in all
English language scholarship of this
time what's really remarkable and what
he says is imagine a Russian peasant
looking at an abstract painting by ilya
repin or excuse me by pablo picasso and
a realist painting by ilya repin this
peasant will look at the cost oh and not
understand it right it will be foreign
it will be unusual there will be no sort
of connection his own reality but we'll
look at the repin and say yes I get it
this relates to me and he uses this to
say Picasso is avant-garde art and repin
is kitsch hi is predigested is far too
easy so this is a moment where the
realist tradition is really rejected for
Western modernist and this is why it
doesn't make it into the Canon in a
later edition of this article Greenberg
will in fact include an addendum and say
actually at the time I realized much
later that at the time I had confused
reckon with somebody else and I'd never
actually seen any of his work my
goodness and so my sort of project or my
method then my method of research was to
kind of correct what Greenberg does
wrong and to actually look at these
these paintings and so I look at them
and I spent a lot of time with each one
of them because I wanted to make an
argument that they were in fact worthy
of extended analysis and worthy of
looking at very carefully and for long
stretches of time okay do you think that
the artists and writers of that period
conversed in any way or have any kind of
conversations were they known to each
other for instance definitely the
Russian artistic sphere at this point
artistic world is very small and mostly
centered in Moscow and st. Petersburg
they're quite simply we're not that many
painters and writers and so they all
knew one another they were all
communicating with one another they did
occupy somewhat different social spheres
which
actually becomes an important part of
the argument writers tended to be of a
higher social class and painters we can
interest we can think for example of
count Lev Tolstoy versus somebody like
idiot repin who is born in a very modest
military settlement in Ukraine so this
also becomes part of the story they
interact but they're not exactly of the
same circle and they're always sort of
lobbying for attention and in particular
the painters are always sort of trying
to become just as good as the literary
tradition so there's quite a bit of
competition between the two okay years
now when you look at the paintings and
read the book is there any correlation
that you can find between you know
painting showing up and written work or
you know kind of written work being
illustrated somehow in paintings
mm-hmm there's quite a bit of crossover
you'll get really explicit examples so
Tolstoy and Anna Karenina will write
about an artist - a Russian artist who's
living in Rome and he in fact paints the
portrait of Honor herself in the save
Sookie's novel the idiot we get explicit
references to whole lines painting of a
painting of dead Christ laying in his
tomb becomes a kind of emblem for the
novel as a whole so there are moments
like this and I do speak about those
although I'm also interested in modes of
representation such as what such as for
example when you're reading a novel and
you come across across a very lengthy
and very picturesque description of a
landscape for me this is a moment when
the novel is sort of turning toward a
visual artistic medium and thinking
about this other art form rather
explicitly and both what it wants to
borrow from it but also how it wants to
distinguish itself from it you'll see
this in painting too with narrative
painting where the painting itself is
sort of trying to tell a story but also
in some sense be optically interesting
okay so who are some of the writers and
artists that you feature in your book
and why mm-hmm
so I hit all
classic as I've mentioned already to
Gainey of Tolstoy Dostoyevsky and for
the painters repin but I also do talk
about some of the lesser-known artists a
good example of this would be a group of
writers and artists who are practicing
in st. Petersburg in the 1840s who call
themselves the natural school and they
are a very small circle again mostly
students the stay of skin toward any of
our part of the circle at one point but
they really their work is marked by this
desire to walk through the city much
like a student would you live in these
not the greatest neighborhood you spend
a lot of your time outdoors walking
through the city sort of conversing with
your friends at cafes and on sidewalks
and they build an artistic aesthetic
based on these experiences of urban life
one of my painters for example pavia
Botha from this period will actually
walk through the cities and peek through
people's windows and he's trying to fix
details from different windows a
chandelier here a scene he witnessed
here a wallpaper design here and he puts
them into these small genre scenes of
merchant life okay and how do you know
that was his technique he writes about
it and in fact his right his friends
will write about it too he was known for
this but he would get up every morning
he would go outside he would walk around
and st. Petersburg in a particular area
is known for having street-level
apartments so it will have windows that
line the street level and he will
discuss the very process of standing and
looking inside of a window and so we see
this again and again in the memoirs and
one of the things I'm arguing that in
that particular chapter is that we as
viewers looking at these paintings which
are very small and packed with detail
also in some sense feel as if we're
peeking through somebody's window that
there's this voyeuristic aspect to our
own experience of the paintings and that
fascinating because it is true realism
that's exactly what's going on right and
it gives it the sort of texture of
reality of authenticity that you too
could have seen this through somebody's
window right so tell us the story about
a repin and Tolstoy and why you
highlight it in the book yeah so I
actually begin with the story in the
book because it's one of these gifts
to a scholar when you come across these
moments where in fact you're two of your
most important subjects two giants of
the artistic tradition in fact meet one
another and then write about it okay and
so I begin here in 1880 Tolstoy has
already written his two major novels war
and peace and Anna Karenina repin has
already become really a major celebrity
in Russia and they are both living and
working in Moscow and one night after
repin has had dinner he hears a knock at
his door he opens the door and there's
this sort of stout older man with a long
white beard and it's Tolstoy and Tolstoy
comes in I did he know who that who it
was at the time well everybody knew what
Tolstoy look looks like he was a
celebrity yes he knew who it was and you
know likely he had a sense that he was
coming over they'd been sort of set up
by a mutual friend and art critic who
knew them both and thought that they
they should really meet okay so you know
repin describes it more dramatically
than it likely was but it was an
incredibly important experience sure
until stoy stays and they talked for
several hours he looks at studies of a
painting that repin is currently working
on and this was a historical painting
from a scene from the 17th century of
Ukrainian Cossacks writing sort of funny
but I guess also kind of rude and maybe
unsavory letter to a Turkish sultan who
had demanded their submission this was
the topic of the painting repens just
beginning to work on it so he shows
Tolstoy to studies and Tolstoy says
they're not very good there's really no
main idea here Wow and weapons really
disturbed this old boy telling you this
and he thinks about it for a few days
and he finally writes Tolstoy back and
he says I appreciate your advice but I'm
going to keep going and I think the main
point is here that perhaps idea means
something very different for a writer
than it does for a painter and it's this
moment where repin realizes that in fact
an idea or even realism itself
might mean something very different in
literature than in painting and that
it's important for him to in some sense
answer this call to realism in a way
that respects his own medium and so this
is one of the big sort of questions that
I'm dealing with in the book is how
these two different art forms really
sort of answer the call of realism in in
very specific particular ways okay and
in doing your research did you look at
what is going on in the rest of the
world during this time period were these
Russian artists influenced by you know
things that are going on in France for
instance or the United States or was it
pretty much an isolated kind of
environment I mean they are very much in
dialogue with what's going on elsewhere
again realism is a transnational
movement it is going on everywhere and
you know one of the interesting aspects
of Russia's particular engagement with
this is that they do it a little bit
later than the rest of the world this is
is almost a cliche of Russian culture
they come to everything a little bit
late and so one of the questions I do
ask them is sort of how much are they
modeling themselves after Western Europe
and how much are they charting their own
path it's a bit of a mixed bag actually
the Russians definitely are in dialogue
they have some connections with what's
going on in France mostly but they
really do attempt to do their own thing
again as I mentioned with Dostoyevsky
he's aiming for the sort of spiritual
realism right this is a kind of realism
that's very different than Balzac who
has a sociological one just as key
legitimately believes that one could in
fact inspire almost Transfiguration in a
novel and so it has a sort of magical
transcendent quality that you would
never encounter anywhere else in the
painterly tradition one argument that is
frequently made is that Russian painting
of this period is more interested in
political narrative okay this is not
entirely the case okay I was going to
ask you are there any kind of political
or government restrictions or issues
with artists and what they write
and paints there are I mean you know
censorship laws are still very much in
place there are a few sort of dramatic
stories of paintings and works of
literature that our either's are taken
down from exhibitions are not allowed to
be published so this is an issue part of
the question with interpreting these
works is that again the Soviet influence
is so strong
the Soviets really wanted to read all of
this as a kind of proto Soviet history
so for them all of these paintings of
everyday life were also about you know
the downtrodden peasants and you know
these were all Pro cursors - the
precursors to the Socialists in the 20th
century and they didn't want to think
about aesthetic issues because for them
technique style form what the painting
looked like would have been a moment of
kind of bourgeois formalism and so part
of what I'm trying to do is recuperate
both sides of these argument say well
actually all of these artists Tolstoy
repin all of them are in some sense
equally interested both in political
ideology and in sort of big spiritual
messages and in technique and style in
something that I think we're more
comfortable thinking of when we consider
French realism or American realism okay
also what do you conclude in your books
so I would say I have two main takeaways
okay or at least this is what I hope now
beyond just you know all of the shore
interesting story yeah the first one
would be that the classic Russian novel
does not emerge in a vacuum that it
emerges very much in dialogue with other
art forms I talk about painting but of
course music and the Performing Arts are
there as well and that it really emerges
as part of this vibrant dynamic cultural
universe and the other one is that
Russian painting of this period is
world-class and it is worthy of being
analyzed as being considered being
looked at that it stands and should
stand next to these celebrated novels of
Tolstoy Dostoevsky but that it should
also stand next to the realist
masterpiece
of Cour de of Akins of Menzel of western
painters were much more familiar with
okay this has been fascinating thank you
thank you very much okay for more
information about Professor Bronson and
her research please visit our website at
macmillan report yale.edu be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Eddie
Macmillan Centre for International and
area studies at Yale
[Music]